we need to support not only trying to
alleviate this in the community uh but
it has been taxing our resources bville
mayor Neil Ellis has taken a drastic
step for his community declaring an
addiction mental health and homelessness
emergency Ellis says there were 16
overdoses on Tuesday just two days later
six more when you declare an emergency
it basically gives you um if there's any
access to funding it it makes you more
of a priority it is the number one
concern of the downtown Mory flunder is
the chair of belleville's business
Improvement Association the Bia runs an
outreach program called welcoming
streets aimed at assisting belleville's
vulnerable population access support but
flunder says despite the efforts of the
Bia and the municipality the crisis is
getting worse and while many businesses
continue to do well according to flunder
the current social issues are having an
impact the perception from a large chunk
of of the community is certainly they
don't want to come down at night for
example uh and we you know who wants
that belleville's police and fire
departments calls for service went up
about 18% in 2023 over the year before
and while some of that can be attributed
to population growth the growing housing
addiction and Mental Health crisis was
also a big part of that increase and has
meant more attention is focused squarely
on the downtown there are two officers
right now assigned to the downtown court
and our community response model as well
as we have members walking the beat as
well as uh there's uh some private
security involved as well the mayor has
now added the emergency declaration to
his effort to get a comprehensive
provincial and federal strategy gold
standard is is housing first uh and
wraparound Services uh whether it be
Mental Health Services drug addiction
services and how do we get there I I
don't see a plan Darren Davis Global
News